okay so i'm just gonna get right into it
um you know
you have had some time to reflect on how
everything went down
big brother canada
how are you feeling right now
morgan i feel amazing i feel so so good
honestly the fact that i made it to week
seven i was more than halfway in the
game in the house i won a pov there's
two other comps that i that i won you
know safety comps that i won for myself
i played the game i left the game as a
pawn so
at the end of the day i've never sat
down and watched everything develop in
front of my eyes i was a part of the
action and i'm so happy that i was like
that and now i get to choose who or help
choose who gets to win the game so what
more could you ask for it's true you're
still in this game in a big way you know
when it was announced that there was a
secret power of veto uh what was going
on in your head at that moment
you know i was looking around the room
trying to figure out who it was and in
my opinion
it was marty and i could see it in his
eyes because i know marty and he's not a
good liar so i was really certain it was
him so i wanted to stand up and prove to
him that i was gonna stand up for him by
committing to him to the rest of the
game and letting him know that if he had
to stand up in front of everyone and
protect me i was going to stand up in
front of everybody and protect him as
well that wasn't enough to get him to
use it unfortunately could have been
anybody else but i knew that i did all
that i could but my heart was in my
throat it was pounding when there was a
secret power of veto yeah i know i know
um you know in your speech you have said
and used some really important words you
said you've been loyal honest and true
you know looking back on how you played
the game would you do anything
differently
the only thing that i say i would maybe
do differently is commit to herman from
the beginning i think him and i really
really understood what we wanted to do
which was be loyal to somebody in the
game and we both chose the wrong person
we decided to be loyal to all these
different other people when him and i at
the end of the day didn't get the
benefit of being a power duo because we
tried to separate ourselves from each
other that's the only thing i would have
done differently but otherwise i was
honest i was true i stuck to my word
throughout the entire game and i never
deviated and i'm proud of myself for
that
that's awesome uh so how has life been
like with vermon in the jury house
a lot of laughs it's been a lot of fun
in the jury house we're you know we're
mixing it up every day we're finding new
and fun things to do um it's really
really enjoyable to be you know spending
time with him in the jury house and
honestly i i think it's great that we
get to look forward to even more people
coming here it's only two of us right
now we could have a triple next week and
have three more join us so it's nice to
have some relaxing down time before this
house gets just as busy as the big
brother house it's so true who would you
love to see walking through the jury
doors next
i won't lie to you i'm still a bit salty
i want to see josh and summer walk
through those doors one of them too i
really want one of them to come in
through the doors because i also think
they'll have a very interesting
perspective on the game and give us more
information on who to vote for but i
would love josh or summer to come
through and i'll say i told y'all the
moose curse is real and you got swiftly
evicted that's all i want in all honesty
um you know you said that it's almost
like down time and jury house right now
until more people show up do you think
you're going to be full-on game mode
when more people come do you have a
strategy in place or do you think you're
actually going to have your guard down a
little bit even in the jury house
i as soon as i left those red doors my
guard was thrown in the garbage i have
been fully relaxed i haven't had any
worries it's not going to be game mode
i'm just going to try to get as much
information about things that i heard
before i left the house to confirm or
deny
you know facts that i was given so
otherwise i'm just chilling i think it's
not going to be full game mode if people
want to come in here in game
they can stay as far away from me as
possible i did enough gaming in my time
but i'm still want to know the
information i still want to know what's
happened in the house when uh since i
left and make sure that i make a choice
with all the factual information that i
have from all the other house guests
yeah um you know when you look back
on your time uh on big brother canada do
you
do you have someone that stands out who
you think is truly pulling the strings
in the house
summer and sails is pulling all the
strings okay it's it's it's palpable the
effect this woman has on everybody in
the house she is so deep with so many
people and hasn't had to prove anything
because she hasn't won a single comp a
power of veto or an hoh she can lay back
relax have no worries and promise the
entire world to everybody in the house
she's so good at having conversations
making people feel deeply connected to
her and she knows everything that's
happening before the rest of the house
knows i don't even know how she does
that but summer summer sales is
definitely the girl that's got all the
strings attached to everybody in the
house and is pulling some for her
you know when you were voted out by a
unanimous vote did you like did you get
a heads up about that did you see that
coming i fully knew it was happening i
went around the house talking to people
and everybody really told me where their
vote was it's been weird this season we
really have been open about where our
votes are going and
the house really doesn't want to turn
against other people in the house after
a crazy flip with the 9-2 step vote um
so it's been really interesting to see
that i definitely was went into it
telling people to just go in the room
and vote that's what you do you tell
erisa what you vote but everybody wanted
to tell me where their vote was going i
still tried to make a last-ditch effort
there uh with kevin and marty to try to
tell them that i could protect them but
alas it didn't work i'm not surprised it
was a unanimous vote because they wanted
to get out of big player and the house
has really been voting all together
throughout the entire season
listen you seem like you're in a good
place you seem like you're happy with
how you played the game you know this is
still going on for you this journey
being in the jury house but if you had
to
sum up this wild journey in one word
what word would it be
you know what the word i would use is
indescribable honestly because i can't
describe everything that happened in one
word and i can't describe the amount of
emotions that i felt the happiness the
sadness the true bliss the fear that you
have in the house it's really really an
indescribable feeling and i'm lucky that
i got to be a part of it
well we are going to continue watching
you and see what happens uh with the
next one uh entering into the jury house
thanks so much for your time i really
appreciate it awesome thanks morgan
appreciate ya
you